قالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الجيش
مازال بعيدا عن تحقيق هدفه بالقضاء على
القدره الصاروخيه لحماس وان هذه المهمه
تحتاج وفق التقديرات الى ما بين عام
وعامين لان الكثير من منصات اطلاق
الصواريخ مدفونه تحت الارض على نحو يصعب
معه على جنود الجيش العثور عليها واضافت
ان التقديرات تشير الى انه مازال بحوزه
حماس نحو ال000 صاروخ حتى الان وقالت
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الدفعه
الصاروخيه التي استهدفت مدينه تل ابيب
الاسبوع الماضي اطلقت من منصات اطلاق كانت
على بعد عشرات الامتار فقط من قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي واضافت الاذاعه ان خليه تابعه
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي ما زالت تعمل في حي
الزيتون بمدينه غزه وتمتلك مخزونا من
الصواريخ هناك وكانت مسؤوله عن جزء كبير
من عمليات اطلاق النار في المنطقه خلال
الاسابيع
الماضيه